Welcome back to the Deep Dive.
Our mission here is, well, it's
pretty simple.
We take a stack of dense
sources, strip away all the
noise, and really pull out the
insights that help you get
better informed.
And today we are taking on one
of history's most familiar
stories.
I mean a story that almost
everyone knows on some level.
Absolutely the flight of Jesus,
Mary and Joseph.
It's such a powerful narrative,
isn't it?
It resonates across cultures and
it's been interpreted in, gosh,
countless ways theologically,
morally, and, and especially in
recent years, politically and.
That political interpretation is
really our starting point for
this deep dive.
It's become very common.
You see it in rhetoric all the
time to label the Holy Family as
refugees or migrants.
It's a very powerful analogy.
It is because it creates this
immediate, visceral connection
to contemporary global crises,
makes an ancient story feel
intensely relevant to today.
But is it accurate?
And that's the question we're
here to explore.
Our deep dive is going to
analyze the historical, the
geographical, and what we could
call the legal realities of the
early 1st century Roman world.
Our whole goal is just clarity
and precision because if we
apply a modern term like
refugee, which is, you know, a
very specific legal category
that was only formalized in the
20th century, we risk committing
a major historical.
Error.
Exactly.
We're imposing our current
political vocabulary onto a
world that simply did not have
the corresponding administrative
structures.
It's like trying to explain
e-mail to a Roman senator.
The framework just isn't there.
OK, let's unpack this then,
because what you're saying is
we're dealing with a system
that's completely alien to our
modern understanding.
Completely.
We're talking about a world with
no nation states, no, you know,
internationally policed borders,
no established asylum law.
None of it.
So if those foundational
elements of our modern world are
missing, then applying modern
legal labels seems, well, it
seems not just inaccurate, but
maybe even misleading about what
their journey was actually like.
Precisely, We have to set the
stage, we need to understand the
geopolitical reality of the
Eastern Mediterranean around the
time of Jesus birth, which
historians, you know, generally
date somewhere between 6:00 and
4:00 BC.
OK.
And the sources are very clear
on this.
The entire region was
politically unified under the
overarching power of Rome.
So step one for the listener is
to just mentally erase the
modern map of the Middle East.
Throw it out.
And instead picture 1 enormous
multi jurisdictional
administration.
Absolutely.
Now let's get specific and look
at the two territories involved
in the story.
First, Judea, their starting
point.
Judea was not an independent
state.
This is critical.
It was what we call a client
Kingdom and it was ruled by
Herod the Great.
A client Kingdom.
So what does that mean in
practical terms?
It means that while Herod was
called a King Rex in Latin, his
authority was completely derived
from and subject to the Roman
Emperor.
He governed at Rome's
discretion.
So he's like a local strongman
has been given a crown, but his
job description is ultimately
written in Rome.
That's a great way to put it.
His power was immense events on
a local level.
He could tax, he could build
massive projects.
And critically for this story,
he had the power of life and
death.
He could execute people.
But that power was fundamentally
contingent.
Always his client status meant
that, you know, while he had
this huge amount of autonomy
over internal affairs, his
legitimacy, his very position,
depended on his loyalty to Rome.
So leaving Herod's territory
didn't mean you were escaping
Roman control.
Not at all.
It just meant moving to a
different Roman jurisdiction.
You were still in the system.
You couldn't escape Roman
identity or Roman control.
OK, so that's Judea.
What about the destination
Egypt?
Egypt had a completely different
administrative setup, which is
just as important to understand.
Egypt was conquered much
earlier, back in 30 BC, and it
was so strategically vital they
often called it the granary of
Rome because of its immense
grain supply that it was treated
as something special.
It wasn't just another province.
No, it wasn't administered by
the Roman Senate, which was
typical for many provinces.
Instead, it was designated as
the personal demand of the
Emperor himself.
The Emperor's personal property.
Essentially, yes.
Yeah.
And it was governed by a man who
wasn't a senator.
An appointee called a prefect or
a prefect is a gypti.
So moving to Egypt wasn't just
moving to a different region, it
was moving into a territory
under the emperor is direct,
immediate control.
And specifically because of its
economic and strategic value.
That's the key difference.
Herod had some local legal and
cultural flexibility in his
Kingdom.
The prefect in Egypt, on the
other hand, was a military and
economic viceroy.
His main job was to ensure the
uninterrupted flow of grain to
Rome.
So the implication of this whole
setup is huge.
Moving from Herod's client
Kingdom in Judea to the
emperor's personal province in
Egypt, It was a relocation
within the boundaries of a
single, unified imperial power.
That's the core of it.
It's basically an internal
transfer.
It's almost like moving from a
state with its own specific
local laws to a federally
administered district like
Washington DC or something.
That analogy helps a lot.
It wasn't crossing a recognized
national boundary in any way
that would trigger our modern
concepts of international law or
visas or border controls
designed to stop people from a
foreign country.
OK, so the administrative stage
is set.
We have one empire, two
different governing styles
within it.
Now let's look at the actual
movements.
And I think we need to start
with the first one, the one in
Luke's gospel, which often gets
mixed up with the flight itself.
Yes, the journey to Bethlehem.
This is so crucial for getting
our definitions clear, isn't?
It absolutely.
The journey to Bethlehem was not
migration.
It wasn't driven by fear or
economic opportunity or anything
like that.
The text says it was about one
thing.
Compliance.
It was about compliance with a
bureaucratic mandate ordered by
Roman authority, a census.
The famous census of Corinius.
Now, we should probably mention
that the historicity of that
specific census is well, it's
hotly debated by scholars.
It is mainly about the timing.
Luke places it around Jesus
birth, but the historical census
of Corinius in Judea is usually
dated to around six AD, which
would be after Herod's death.
But for our purposes here, that
debate is almost secondary.
It is.
What matters is the underlying
reality that the text is
portraying, which is an Imperial
administration frustrative act.
So whether the census was dated
precisely or whether Luke was
using the idea to frame his
narrative, the purpose of the
journey was internal travel for
bureaucratic reasons and most
importantly for taxation.
The sources are clear.
This was mandatory travel.
So the family was traveling to
be counted and taxed, all under
the Roman system.
This movement fits entirely
within the normal mandated
functions of the Imperial
administration.
Exactly.
Census movements were a common,
if very burdensome, part of life
in the Roman world.
There's nothing in the text that
suggests this travel involved
crossing into foreign territory
or seeking a new political
identity or changing their legal
status.
It was just a mandatory journey.
It fits none of our modern
categories of refugee or even
voluntary immigrant.
The administrative nature of it
defines it.
It does.
OK, I have to push back a little
here though, because while the
Bethlehem journey was
bureaucratic, the flight to
Egypt was clearly driven by
terror.
No question.
I mean, even if they stayed
within the Roman Empire, their
motive was fear of violence, so
doesn't that fear, regardless of
borders surely align with the
moral reality of the modern term
refugee?
That is a necessary challenge,
and it gets to the heart of why
this is so complex.
We have to separate the moral
truth from the historical legal
category.
OK, So yes, the motivation for
the flight to Egypt, which we
write about in Matthew's Gospel,
was acute danger.
They were fleeing Herod's intent
to kill infants.
The family was absolutely
fleeing persecution.
That is the moral truth.
But the crucial distinction
remains the legal mechanism that
was available to them, or more
accurately, the complete lack of
1.
So tell us more about the
practical mechanics of this How
did a Carpenter, his wife, and a
newborn baby actually move
across 2 significant
jurisdictions without any formal
paperwork?
This is where we need to talk
about something called the ISIS
Gentium, which was a kind of law
of nations used within the Roman
framework.
It governed relations between
Romans and non Romans and it
generally facilitated internal
movement.
So Roman policy actually
encouraged travel.
To a degree, yes.
Travel for trade, for commerce,
for settlement across the
Mediterranean, it was all
essential for maintaining the
Pax Romana.
Great Roman peace.
Exactly.
So for a subject moving between,
say, Julia and Egypt, both under
Roman control, there were no
official customs posts demanding
passports or visas like we have
today.
The travel was essentially open,
but, and this is a big but, that
freedom was often conditional.
Conditional what?
Well, conditional on safety,
money and patronage, travel was
expensive, it was slow, and it
could be very dangerous because
of bandits on the roads or
pirates at sea.
Right?
So if you were a subject,
particularly a Jew, there were
established Jewish diaspora
communities all across the
Empire, You would have to rely
on that existing network.
You'd need letters of
introduction from a local patron
or a religious leader to make
sure you'd be welcomed and have
shelter when you arrive arrived
in a place like Alexandria.
And Alexandria had a massive,
well established Jewish
population at the time.
Huge.
One of the largest in the world.
So their safety when they
arrived in Egypt wasn't
guaranteed by some formal asylum
process, but by leveraging
existing community and family
ties?
Yes, and by the general freedom
of movement that the Roman
Empire itself guaranteed.
Exactly right.
Egypt offered a different
governing authority, the
prefect, who was physically and
politically distant from Herod,
that provided the necessary
physical safety, but it did not
offer a different national legal
category.
It was, as we said, relocation
within Empire.
So if we connect this to the
bigger picture, the modern
refugee definition requires
fleeing persecution from one
sovereign entity to seek
protection from a completely
different sovereign entity.
Yes, that's the key.
And what's so fascinating here
is a complete absence of that
crucial political mechanism.
The family fled a local ruler,
Herod, but they fled into the
wider administrative territory
of the very same empire that
authorized that local ruler in
the first place.
The overarching power structure
remained constant.
There was no international law
for them to appeal to.
There was no second sovereign
state that could grant them
asylum against the first.
Their movement was a lateral
shift in jurisdiction, not an
escape across international
lines.
Which brings us squarely to
Section 2, this whole problem of
anachronism.
It really seems like we're
trying to transpose a 20th
century legal framework onto a
1st century imperial reality
just because the moral weight of
the story is so compelling.
And that is precisely the
historians challenge.
Applying modern terminology
imposes our contemporary, non
equivalent concepts onto these
ancient systems.
Anachronism, even when it's
well-intentioned, just obscures
history.
It doesn't clarify it.
Let's actually list those
specific modern frameworks that
were fundamentally missing in
the 1st century, because I think
seeing the list is essential to
really understanding the
distinction.
The lack of these frameworks is
the foundation of the entire
argument.
So the 1st century simply did
not possess national passports.
You need a nation state to issue
a passport.
Right.
No nation state, no passport.
It didn't have immigration
quotas, which are designed to
regulate the flow of non
citizens, and it didn't have
formalized codified deportation
procedures as instruments of
international law.
And, most relevantly for this
discussion, the entire apparatus
of asylum adjudication was
missing.
Completely the systems where a
sovereign nation or an
international body assesses a
claim for protection against the
claimant's home government that
just didn't exist.
Those concepts are so much more
recent.
They post date the event by
centuries the modern state
system with its defined
impermeable boundaries and the
international treaty apparatus
that governs refugee status that
only really started to come
together with the Treaty of
Westphalia in the 17th century.
And it didn't really reach his
full legal maturity until after
World War 2.
With the 1951 Refugee
Convention, exactly that
convention is the cornerstone.
That's where the formal legal
definition of refugee that we
use today comes from, isn't it?
It is The convention was
designed specifically to address
the unprecedented displacement
and statelessness that was
caused by two world wars and the
political upheavals that
followed.
It defines A refugee as someone
who is outside their country of
nationality or habitual
residence.
Outside their country.
Yes, and who is unable or
unwilling to return because of a
well founded fear of being
persecuted?
So if they never left the
boundaries of their habitual
residents, which was the Roman
Empire, they cannot technically
meet the foundational criteria
of the modern definition.
Correct.
While they certainly fled
danger, the legal category of
refugee is not historically or
legally transferable to their
status within the Roman imperial
system.
They lacked the necessary
external sovereign entity to
recognize and protect them
against their own sovereign
entity, because at the end of
the day, Rome was ultimately
both.
OK, let's dedicate some serious
time here to just dissecting the
specific terms, because the way
language is used rhetorically
today just collapses these
really critical differences.
We have to.
I mean, the distinction between
these terms is crucial for
intellectual integrity.
So let's start again with
refugee.
We've established it's a modern
legal category.
Yes, a legal status formalized
in the mid 20th century.
It requires recognition by a
receiving state or an
international body, and that
recognition grants specific
rights and protections.
Many, many displaced people
throughout history who fled
persecution were never refugees
in this sense, because no
sovereign entity recognized
their status under these terms.
OK, Next up, the word flight.
Flight is purely descriptive.
It's just the act of departing
specifically to escape danger.
That danger could be a local
crime, a natural disaster, or
state violence.
Mary, Joseph, and Jesus
definitely undertook flight.
This is the morally true and
historically accurate
descriptive term.
And how's that different from
exile?
Exile usually implies a degree
of political or communal
coercion.
It describes a removal or
departure from a homeland, often
for ideological or punitive
reasons.
Think of the great historical
exiles of the Jewish people,
like the Babylonian exile.
So it's often a mass event.
It often is, and while the
family's departure was
involuntary and driven by
political violence, the scale
and the very individualized
nature of their flight makes it
slightly distinct from those
mass state mandated exiles.
Got it.
And what about migration?
Migration is the most general
term of all.
It just describes movement.
It's often for economic or
environmental reasons, and it
doesn't inherently imply danger
or coercion.
A Roman merchant moving to
Alexandria for Better Business
is a migrant.
A person fleeing localized
violence is also technically a
migrant, but the term lacks the
specificity we really need for
this historical analysis.
OK, finally, let's tackle
asylum.
You said earlier that formal
asylum didn't exist, but surely
there were ancient forms of
sanctuary or protection they
could seek out?
That's a crucial point, and we
have to elaborate here.
While the modern legal mechanism
of asylum, which presumes a
receiving state capable of
legally protecting A foreigner
against their home state, did
not exist, ancient societies
absolutely had concepts of
sanctuary and protection.
So what did those ancient forms
of protection look like?
Well, they often relied on the
religious law or local
patronage.
For instance, seeking sanctuary
often meant literally fleeing to
a temple or a sacred precinct.
Ah, so it's religious
protection, not a state one.
Exactly.
It was not state granted asylum,
it was temporary protection
granted by religious custom or
priestly authority.
And that protection often ended
the moment the local authorities
decided it was time for you to
leave.
So if Joseph and Mary entered
Egypt, they weren't walking into
a government office and filling
out a form to seek state
protection from Herod.
Not at all.
They were relying on physical
distance, the fact that Egypt's
prefect operated independently
of Herod and, crucially, the
shelter provided by that
thriving Jewish community in
Alexandria.
Precisely.
They were leveraging the
pre-existing stability and
infrastructure of the Jewish
diaspora community, all within
the Roman system.
The move was successful not
because a legal mechanism
offered them asylum, but simply
because the local authorities in
Egypt had no reason or
motivation to cooperate with
Herod's localized political
purge.
It was a bureaucratic transfer,
not a legal status change.
And if we connect this to the
bigger picture, this distinction
matters because when we use
precise language, we preserve
the unique moral and historical
challenges that ancient people
actually face.
We avoid giving historical
weight to modern institutions
that just weren't part of their
reality.
We avoid confusing a moral
imperative.
The family was in danger and
needed safety with a specific
legal definition that is
entirely anachronistic and
requires a completely different
geopolitical setup.
OK, let's pivot now to Section
3, because even if we set aside
all the technical legal points,
the narrative context itself,
the actual story as it's
recorded in Matthew, it diverges
from a typical historical or
political flight in a really
crucial way.
It does.
And this is the supernatural
dimension.
Here's where it gets really
interesting.
The biblical narrative frames
this entire episode not as a
generalized political upheaval,
you know, a collective response
to some social injustice.
It's framed as a direct,
divinely guided response to a
very specific, localized threat.
Right.
The family didn't react to
rumors spreading across the
country or to a political decree
that was posted in Town Square.
No, the sources highlight that
the entire chain of events was
precipitated and guided by
supernatural revelation.
Herod's actions are driven by
his own paranoia and his
response to a prophetic claim,
the arrival of the Magi
signaling a future king.
And Joseph's decision making.
It's entirely dictated by
angelic guidance delivered in a
dream.
An Angel tells him where to go
and just as importantly, when to
return.
Which makes this flight unique,
doesn't it?
Joseph's actions are dictated by
personal obedience to a
perceived divine command.
He's not petitioning A
bureaucrat or making it
administrative decision or even
taking counsel from his
community.
That is the defining
characteristic of the story.
You contrast this with
historical precedents for
political exile, like the mass
flight of Jews after the
destruction of the Second Temple
in 70 AD.
In that case, safety depended on
community coordination, on
strategic negotiation with Roman
legions on mass flight paths.
Joseph's flight is hyper
individual.
He didn't consult a map to find
the safest route.
He followed a divine instruction
to go to Egypt and stay there
until he received a second,
equally divine instruction.
Exactly.
The source material is really
pointing out that this was not a
generalized ethnic flight or
some kind of population level
displacement.
The danger was incredibly
specific.
It was targeting one child,
Jesus.
The warning was personal, it was
given to Joseph and the
instructions were directed to a
single household.
This really forces us to think
about the theological precedent
here.
If the family's safety relied on
divine intervention, how does
that change our understanding of
protection in a world that
didn't have state codified
asylum?
It changes everything.
It suggests that in the absence
of formalized state mechanisms
for protection, safety reverts
to other things, individual
obedience, local relationships,
or divine will.
The narrative implicitly
positions God as the provider of
safe passage, overriding all the
political and geographical
constraints.
And Matthew's Gospel is very
explicit about this, isn't it?
He frames the flight and the
return as the fulfillment of
prophecy.
Yes, out of Egypt, I called my
son.
The narrative's main function
isn't just historical reporting
on migration patterns, it's a
theological assertion about the
identity of this child.
So it's both.
It's a historical account of
events, but it's also a
theological commentary on.
Them it is by emphasizing divine
instruction, the narrative
becomes less about the politics
of displacement and more about
destiny and the fulfillment of
scripture.
Joseph wasn't seeking asylum, he
was executing a divine travel
plan that was designed to
circumvent Herod's malice.
OK, let's move on to the scale
of the event, which is equally
important in contextualizing why
this was not a refugee crisis as
we understand the term today.
Modern crises involve mass
demographic shifts.
And the scale of this event is
often dramatically inflated in
modern rhetoric.
When we discuss modern refugee
crises, we are often talking
about millions of displaced
people spilling across multiple
national borders. 1st century
Judea simply did not have the
population density to support
that kind of displacement.
Can you give us some demographic
estimates just to ground us in
the reality of the time?
Well, estimates vary, of course,
but the entire population of
Judea and Galilee combined was
likely in the hundreds of
thousands, not millions.
Jerusalem itself was densely
populated for an ancient city,
but Bethlehem, the site of the
massacre, was a minuscule
settlement.
It probably only housed a few
1000 people at most.
So the massacre of the
innocents, while horrific and
absolutely a state sponsored
crime, would have impacted a
very unlimited, very local
population.
Precisely.
If we accept the historicity of
the event, the number of infants
killed would have been
relatively small, reflecting the
size of the village.
The source material emphasizes
that this was not a nation scale
demographic displacement event.
It was a highly localized
atrocity that resulted in an
individualized flight for
safety.
And this context of scale is so
vital, it allows us to view the
event with the gravity it
deserves.
It was a terrible act of
localized political violence
without distorting it into an
analogy for a 21st century mass
migration crisis.
It allows us to maintain the
moral clarity of Herod's
brutality without sacrificing
historical and demographic
accuracy.
The Holy Family's journey,
therefore, was a singular,
divinely directed internal
relocation for personal safety,
impacting a small community.
Which brings us to our final
section, the implications and
final thoughts.
Why does this precision matter
so much?
I mean, if the moral lesson is
the same, that we should show
compassion to those fleeing
violence, why spend all this
time correcting the terminology?
It matters because historical
accuracy is paramount.
This discussion is emphatically
not meant to diminish the
severity of Harrah's actions or
the very real danger that Mary
and Joseph faced.
The moral imperative to offer
welcome and aid to those fleeing
violence remains incredibly
powerful.
But the goal is linguistic
integrity.
Yes, the goal is to maintain
precision in our historical
language.
When we apply modern legal
frameworks, we inadvertently
project the institutional
conflicts of the 20th and 21st
centuries, things like nation
states, border conflicts,
international law, onto an
ancient context where those
conditions just didn't exist.
Historical language must reflect
the operational reality of the
time being discussed, not our
current political reality.
So what does this all mean for
the listener who's trying to
grasp the legal and identity
context of the time?
Can you give us a final
synthesis of the travel reality
in the Roman Empire?
I think we can synthesize it
into a few key takeaways.
First, the absence of modern
state controls meant that travel
was generally open and free
between provinces and client
kingdoms.
Within the Roman sphere.
This was facilitated by that
concept of Ekis gentium.
Second, movement was primarily
restricted by practical factors,
the cost of travel, safety from
brigands, and the need for
reliable local patronage or
letters of introduction to
secure lodging.
It wasn't restricted by national
borders or international
immigration statutes.
And most definitively, the
entire movement from the
mandatory census journey to the
flight to Egypt was an internal
relocation within the Roman
imperial structure.
That is the ultimate legal
summary.
They moved from a Roman client
Kingdom to an imperial Roman
province.
They never ceased being subjects
within the Pax Romana.
Their identity remained
constant, and their ultimate
legal authority, Caesar,
remained exactly the same.
We've established this strong
clear distinction between the
theological or moral
interpretation of the flight and
the legal and historical reality
of the relocation.
We've broken down the missing
frameworks and the necessity of
precision.
So now it's time for our final
provocative thought for the
listener.
OK, building on the narrative's
reliance on specific divine
instruction, the angelic dream,
rather than on political
negotiation or communal flight,
we want to propose this question
for you to think about.
If the movement was purely
theological and internal to 1
overarching empire, how does the
narrative specific choice to
emphasize divine command change
how we understand the nature of
protection and safety in the
ancient world?
It seems to suggest that where
state mechanisms were localized
and unreliable, as Herod's power
clearly was, safety wasn't found
in some higher legal authority
because that didn't exist.
It was found in an appeal to a
supernatural one.
It forces us to consider that in
the absence of formalized
international mechanisms like
asylum, safety was viewed as
entirely dependent on factors
outside the political sphere,
individual obedience, local
community consent, or divine
intervention.
So the story of the flight to
Egypt is maybe less a statement
about migration law.
And more a profound exploration
of how destiny and protection
operate when the rule of law is
imperfect, localized, and easily
corrupted by client kings.
A fascinating way to
contextualize the entire story,
not as a contemporary political
statement, but as a statement
about faith and survival within
a specific, massive, ancient
structure.
Thank you for guiding us through
this incredibly detailed and
precise deep dive.
It's always a pleasure to help
uncover the historical facts
that are sometimes hidden
beneath modern interpretation.
We encourage you to reflect on
how often modern frameworks can
distort ancient realities and to
always seek that historical
precision.
To the debate, we'll catch you
on the Today we're focusing on,
well, one of the most culturally
significant and I think often
contested passages in the New
Testament, the count of Jesus,
Mary, and Joseph's flight to
Egypt as it's documented in the
Gospel of Matthew.
And it's a foundational
narrative of displacement, which
is really why it holds such
resonance for us today.
Absolutely.
The the historical fact of their
movement out of Judea to escape
Herod's violence isn't really in
dispute.
However, in our contemporary
discourse, this movement is
almost universally characterized
using modern legal and political
terminology, specifically words
like refugee or migrant.
And that is precisely where the
substantive disagreement lies,
isn't it?
The application of these
contemporary labels to ancient
events introduces an immense
legal and historical
anachronism.
Correct.
So the central question we have
to address today is this is the
application of modern legal
terminology such as refugee to
the Holy Family's relocation
historically and well, legally
appropriate given the political
realities of the 1st century
Roman Empire.
My position on this is quite
clear.
The movement was strictly an
internal relocation within a
unified Roman imperial system,
and therefore modern refugee
terminology is fundamentally
incompatible with the historical
context.
And I would say I accept the
historical and legal limits of
the ancient system.
I mean, no one is arguing for
20th century asylum courts in
four BC.
However, I argue that focusing
solely on that legal precision
obscures the the substantive
reality of their situation.
They were engaged in a life or
death flight from targeted state
violence.
So the rhetorical use of refugee
or, you know, related terms, it
attempts to capture that
political and moral severity, a
severity that transcends the
technical definition of a modern
border.
OK, so to understand why the
term refugee fails, we really
must first establish the
political geography.
My core argument is rooted in
this idea of the unity of the
Roman world, the relocation from
Judea to Egypt.
It occurred entirely within the
administrative boundaries of a
single imperial power.
Let's let's just clarify the
jurisdictions involved.
Judea at this time was a client
Kingdom ruled by Herod the
Great, and a client king was,
well, highly autonomous
domestically, but absolutely
subordinate to Rome's strategic
and foreign policy goals.
Which is a key distinction.
It is, yes, but the distinction
doesn't create an international
border.
And crucially, Egypt was not
another client Kingdom or some
independent entity.
It had been a Roman imperial
province since the defeat of
Cleopatra and 30 BC.
It was governed directly by a
Roman prefect acting explicitly
on behalf of the emperor, and
was treated essentially as
Rome's bread basket, a vital
piece of internal
infrastructure.
So therefore, when Joseph moved
his family, they were simply
traveling between two different
administrative subdivisions of
the same supreme governing
authority.
Travel between these two zones,
a client Kingdom and a province.
It just did not involve crossing
a foreign national border,
because that concept, as defined
by modern international law,
simply did not exist.
There was no mechanism for
granting asylum from one
sovereign nation to another.
The family retained their
identity and their legal
category as subjects of the
Roman Empire, merely moving from
Herod's jurisdiction to the
provincial jurisdiction of the
prefect in Egypt.
For safety.
This is internal relocation.
Full stop.
I grant you every point on the
administrative structure I do.
I agree that classifying them as
having achieved refugee status,
which is a creation of post
World War 2 international legal
conventions, is historically
indefensible.
But the question is whether
historical accuracy should
always trump moral and political
clarity.
I mean, focusing solely on the
lack of a modern legal status
ignores the terror of the
substantive reality they were
fleeing State sanctioned
violence, the execution of
infants ordered by a head of
state.
You know, the source material
itself gives us a critical
intellectual tool here, the
distinction between the modern
legal status of refugee and the
historical reality of flight,
which is simply departure to
escape immediate danger without
any need for legal recognition.
The family was engaged in flight
driven by a very specific,
personalized and lethal threat.
And the fact that the entire
Roman Empire was technically a
single space for movement, that
actually illustrates the lack of
agency the family had.
When they moved for the census
in Luke, it was because of a
Roman mandate.
When they fled in Matthew, it
was to escape a local Roman
client ruler.
The political severity of the
coercion is undeniable, and that
political severity is what
modern terminology, however
legally and accurate, is trying
to capture.
I see why you emphasize the
moral imperative of flight.
I do.
But let me give you a different
perspective on why that
definitional precision is so
necessary.
The modern term refugee isn't
just descriptive, it's
prescriptive.
It's tied to the 1951 Refugee
Convention and it requires
formal recognition, non
refuelment, protection, and
often resettlement.
The failure to use precise
language, choosing refugee over,
say, political exiles or maybe
those in flight.
It imposes A contemporary
bureaucratic infrastructure onto
the ancient world.
When listeners hear refugee,
they immediately conjure images
of border checkpoints, asylum
applications, immigration quotas
and, you know, perhaps even
debates over deportation.
This fundamentally misrepresents
how people moved and were
governed under Roman power.
No 1st century person, no matter
how dire their situation, could
appeal to an external sovereign
entity for refugee status.
By insisting on this inaccurate
term, we commit a serious
categorical error that prevents
us from truly analyzing the
unique mechanisms of Roman
administration and the relative
power of client kings like
Herod.
Of the legal infrastructure.
But I would argue that
intellectual rigor does not
require us to abandon the
rhetorical power of the term
entirely, especially when it
clarifies the nature of the
oppression we are debating.
Labels, yes, but those labels
resonate because they speak to a
timeless human experience of
displacement due to state
tyranny.
And consider the distinction
between Herod, the client king,
and the Roman prefect in Egypt.
Herod had the executive latitude
to engage in personalized,
localized acts of mass murder.
As the narrative describes,
While he was technically a Roman
subject, his power allowed him
to act as an unconstrained
tyrant in his territory.
So moving out of Judea was
moving away from that specific
form of power.
The moral resonance of refugee
captures this vulnerability.
They were powerless subjects
fleeing a governing body that
sought their extermination.
Should we really privilege the
technical administrative
boundary over the life or death
situation it represented?
We must, because the nuance of
that administrative boundary is
exactly what made their journey
successful.
And that brings us to contention
too, the significance of the
political geography.
You correctly point out that
they withdrew from Herod's
specific lethal jurisdiction.
But this functional distinction,
it has to be kept within its
proper legal container.
Look Roman subjects throughout
the empire, whether they were
merchants, officials, or
laborers, they had the legal
right to travel widely for
safety, commerce, or trade
without needing visas or border
admissions.
The fact that moving from Judea
to Egypt offered safety actually
proves my point.
It demonstrates the unity of the
imperial legal system and its
administrative stability despite
local variation in governance.
They were moving from one part
of the Roman world that had a
localized problem, Herod's
paranoia, to another part that
did not.
They never changed their
fundamental legal identity.
Now, if they had fled to the
Parthian Empire, Rome's great
rival across the Euphrates, then
we would be discussing
international asylum.
But moving 400 miles within the
Roman dominion makes them, by
historical standards, internally
displaced persons, not
international refugees.
I'm not convinced by that line
of reasoning, because it
minimizes the practical
difference between a client
Kingdom and a province.
A client king like Herod
possessed far greater, often
unchecked power over life and
death than a direct Roman
provincial governor or prefect
who was beholden to centralized
bureaucratic oversight and, you
know, the emperor's political
calculus.
So while you're right that they
retain their abstract identity
as Roman subjects, practically
speaking, the administrative
boundary between Herod's domain
and the prefect's domain in
Egypt functioned as a boundary
of lethal risk.
The appendix confirms that
Herod's power to execute
unilaterally was limited by his
territory.
Crossing into Egypt meant
entering A jurisdiction where
the local ruler was not
personally invested in the
infant's death.
The fact that the flight worked
is evidence that the boundary,
though technically internal to
Rome, was functionally external
to that specific zone of mortal
danger.
The misleading part is equating
a subject's abstract Roman
identity with the practical lack
of protection from localized
tyranny.
That brings us to a crucial
element that distinguishes this
narrative from, well, from
virtually all historical
examples of flight, and that is
contention 3 the role of the
supernatural and the specificity
of the danger.
Most historical patterns of
flight involve generalized
ethnic persecution, mass
population displacement, or
organized political resistance
seeking collective asylum.
The biblical narrative is unique
because the entire event, the
necessity of the flight, the
timing, the destination, it was
all precipitated and guided by
supernatural revelation.
An Angel warns Joseph in a
dream, and the motivation is
explicitly linked to Messianic
prophecy.
This element fundamentally
removes the event from the
standard human paradigm of
seeking asylum or political
refuge.
They weren't petitioning a
foreign state for protection,
they were following a divine
private strategy for protection
directed to a single household.
This reinforces the idea of a
targeted withdrawal planned not
by human political actors, but
by a higher power, which further
isolates it from the category of
refugee status, which inherently
requires human political
negotiation.
I come at it from a different
way when assessing the impact of
that theological dimension.
Because regardless of the
mechanism of the warning,
whether Joseph receives a dream
or obtained high level political
intelligence from a spy, the
result is identical in political
terms.
Flight from an act of state
ordered murder.
The theological context dictates
the why of the escape, sure.
But the political.
Context dictates the ACT.
Carrot's reaction, the massacre
of the innocents, was a purely
political response to a
perceived dynastic threat.
The state treated the flight as
a political threat requiring a
violent, repressive response.
The fact that God intervened to
give the warning does not negate
the political reality of the
displacement, nor does it
diminish the tyranny they were
resisting.
To suggest the supernatural
guidance somehow makes their
flight less real or less severe
than if they had fled based on a
rumor is, well, it's to confuse
theology with political science.
But it's not about severity,
it's about category.
If they were seeking asylum in
the modern sense, they would be
engaging with the structures of
the receiving state.
Their divine guidance meant they
didn't need to ask permission or
fill out paperwork, or rely on
the charity or policy of the
Egyptian prefect.
They simply went relying on the
administrative openness of the
Roman system.
So to use refugee, a term
steeped in the bureaucratic
complexity of international law,
it just undermines the
singularity of this divinely
guided withdrawal.
It was a strategic movement to
evade a single localized threat,
not a plea for collective
protection.
But the core vulnerability
remains the same.
We must not allow legal
definitions to over shadow the
human and political stakes, to
classify this journey merely as
internal relocation for safety,
which is something a Roman tax
collector or merchant might do
routinely.
It fails to capture the gravity.
Failure to relocate meant the
execution of a child.
We have to be able to use
language that communicates both
the cold administrative fact
internal Roman movement and the
burning political reality flight
from imminent murder.
When we use the term refugee
rhetorically, we are speaking to
the second, more profound
reality.
And that rhetorical application,
while powerful, sacrifices
precision.
If we broaden the definition of
refugee to encompass any
historical flight from state
danger, regardless of
international borders or legal
status, the term loses all
specific meaning.
It ceases to be an academic
category, and it becomes merely
a synonym for any victim of
tyranny, past or present.
While that's understandable in
modern moral discourse, this
blurring is catastrophic for
historical analysis.
I disagree that it's
catastrophic.
I think it is.
Perhaps clarifying it forces us
to ask what is the true function
of classifying displacement?
Is it to satisfy the
requirements of 20th century
treaties?
Or is it to understand the
enduring phenomenon of the
marginalized fleeing state
violence?
It has to be both.
We owe the historical figures
the respect of describing their
political environment
accurately.
And we owe the narrative the
respect of acknowledging the
existential reality of the
danger they faced.
Conclusion Our discussion today
really centers on this tension
between historical precision and
moral resonance.
I must reiterate the paramount
importance of maintaining
precision in historical
language.
The movement of Jesus, Mary, and
Joseph was strictly defined by
the realities of the Roman
imperial system.
It was relocation within the
administrative boundaries of a
unified empire.
Therefore, regardless of the
unique and undeniable
seriousness of Herod's threat,
we cannot retroactively and
accurately label them with 20th
century legal terminology like
refugee.
Doing so sacrifices critical
historical and legal context for
the convenience of modern
political language.
They were internally displaced
persons fleeing localized state
violence, and acknowledging that
detail allows us to understand
the unique reach and structure
of Roman power.
And I affirm the technical
accuracy of the Roman political
structure and the lack of a
modern international border.
That is the legal frame.
But I have to insist that the
substantive reality of fleeing
immediate, targeted violence is
the essential component of the
Matthew narrative, and it can't
be dismissed by a hyper focus on
legal anachronism.
We must recognize the category
of flight from danger, a
desperate move predicated on
avoiding state execution.
While refugee is legally
inaccurate, it speaks to the
moral condition of people
seeking safety under duress, a
condition that transcends
geography.
Complexity often requires
multiple perspectives to fully
appreciate the context, weighing
the legal facts against the
moral weight of the
displacement.
Indeed, and examining the source
material through the lens of
both strict legal definitions
and contemporary rhetorical
framing, I think it deepens our
understanding not only of 1st
century mobility, but also of
how our modern political
language shapes our view of
history.
Right.
The legal facts speak to the
lack of modern infrastructure,
while the narrative speaks to
the timeless immediate reality
of political violence and the
vulnerability of the powerless.
A critical distinction and one
that continues to demand careful
consideration.
Welcome to the Thank you for
joining us.
This week we're looking at
excerpts from Jesus.
Mary and Joseph were Not
Refugees.
Right.
And the peace argues that the
Holy Family's flight to Egypt
was an internal relocation
inside the Roman Empire, not a
modern refugee situation.
It's a very rigorous argument.
Let's get right into it.
The material makes a really
strong case for historical
precision.
Absolutely.
It highlights that 1st century
Judea and Egypt were both, you
know, firmly within the Roman
sphere.
So there's no foreign border
crossing.
Exactly.
And no modern asylum law to
speak of.
The historical foundation is
impeccable, really.
It is.
The research is just so solid on
that point.
But, and this is where I think
we can push it, there's a big
opportunity to maximize the
impact, to really answer the So
what question.
OK, the material effectively
establishes historical
precision, but its current
conclusion could maximize impact
by more deeply exploring the
contemporary implication and
stakes of the terminological
correction.
Right, you're talking about
Section 7, Why this distinction
matters.
I am.
The weakness is that it's just,
it's too short right now.
It leans very heavily on the
academic need for precision.
You know, avoiding anachronism.
And that risks it being seen as
just a semantic point.
Exactly.
A purely academic exercise.
It doesn't really grapple with
the fact that the word refugee
today carries enormous political
and emotional weight.
The argument stops just short of
explaining why it's so vital we
protect that terms legal
boundaries for, well, for modern
humanitarian reasons.
I see the potential trap there.
I mean, if you spend 5 sections
building this incredibly
detailed historical case, you
have to defend why those details
matter now.
Right.
But doesn't that risk diluting
the focus the author so clearly
wants to stay anchored in the
1st century?
I get that, and the goal isn't
to inject a bunch of modern
politics into it.
Not at all.
OK.
The goal is to show the ethical
and the legal cost of being lazy
with our terms.
So my suggestion is to reframe
that final section Section 7 to
really bridge that gap.
Between the ancient history and
the modern use of the word yes.
To show what we actually lose
when this hard won legal
category of refugee, which you
know was formalized after World
War 2 for a very specific
reasons, gets stretched too
thin.
So how do you make that
actionable?
How do you do that without the
paper suddenly becoming, I don't
know, a policy proposal?
You focus on legal integrity.
For instance, the author could
expand on how misusing the term
refugee inadvertently diminishes
the specific protections that
are codified in international
law.
OK, explain that a bit more.
Well, the term was created to
protect someone who has to cross
an international border because
their own state can't or won't
protect them, right?
If any dangerous journey
throughout history gets labeled
A refugee situation, the term
loses its legal sharpness.
It loses its focus on that very
specific crisis at a national
border.
I see.
That's a powerful shift.
It's not just about correcting a
historical mistake, it's about
protecting a modern legal tool.
Precisely.
It turns the argument into
something that protects the most
vulnerable people today.
I remember the material defines
other terms too, Flight, exile,
migration.
It does, and that's the way
forward.
The author could use those.
Yes, use their own precise terms
to offer a better model for
talking about displacement.
Today show that the Holy Family
situation is much closer to what
the author calls flight escaping
danger, but without the legal
implications.
And then you contrast that with
a legally defined modern refugee
crisis.
Exactly.
It operationalizes their
scholarship.
It goes from you're wrong to use
this word to here's a better,
more accurate word, and here's
why using the right word
matters.
So it provides a clean
alternative.
It answers that reader's
question of OK, So what?
It does.
It turns a historical correction
into a really useful tool for
ethical and precise language.
OK, that's a fantastic point.
It really raises the stakes for
the conclusion.
Let's shift gears a bit.
Let's look at the structure,
specifically section 6.
The.
Supernatural dimension.
Yes, it's a fascinating point,
the author notes.
The flight was guided by, you
know, a dream, an Angel.
It was a supernatural
revelation.
A brilliant observation, truly.
And the argument is that this
makes the flight unique.
It was personal, not some kind
of community wide bureaucratic
process.
It is a great insight, but it
feels structurally isolated.
How?
So.
The distinct analysis of the
narrative supernatural dimension
provides a powerful counterpoint
to political readings, but
structurally it feels isolated
and interrupts the logical flow
of the historical legal
analysis.
I mean you have 5 sections of
really grounded empirical
argument, administration, Roman
law, terminology, and then
suddenly boom section 6 is all
about angels and dreams and then
it goes back to the historical
argument in the conclusion.
Right.
It's a jarring pivot.
It risks, you know, pulling the
reader out of that rigorous
historical mindset.
It feels a bit like an appendix
that got dropped into the middle
of the paper.
I can see the interruption.
Yeah, but isn't that point so
strong, so unique, that it
deserves its own spotlight?
I worry if it's integrated too
early it might make the whole
thing sound more like a
theological paper.
That's the challenge, but the
goal is to make it serve the
historical argument, not stand
apart from it.
So what's the suggestion?
My suggestion is to integrate it
much earlier, use it not as a
theological point to be debated,
but is very specific evidence of
the, well, the extreme
specificity of the event.
To reinforce the main thesis.
Exactly to reinforce that this
wasn't some generalized mass
displacement.
So you're saying fold the
theological detail back into the
historical context?
Let's get concrete.
You can move this idea into to
say Section 4 on the anachronism
problem, and you explicitly
connect the supernatural
guidance to the nature of the
threat.
The danger wasn't famine or war,
it was highly specific.
Herod wanting to kill infants in
one town, Bethlehem, because of
a prophecy.
The warning was personal to
Joseph.
And the escape was an act of
individual obedience.
It's a surgical threat and a
surgical response.
That's a great distinction, and
you can contrast that with a
mass displacement.
Right.
The author even notes that
Herod's actions were shaped by
prophecy and Joseph's by a
divine warning.
So the whole conflict is driven
by these non political, non
administrative forces.
Which further separates it from
a typical case for political
asylum.
Yes.
By integrating it, you
strengthen the entire
architecture of the paper.
You show that every single
detail of the story argues
against the modern refugee
label.
So it's no longer a stand alone
point about angels.
No, it becomes a point about the
singularity of the threat driven
by sources completely outside
Rome's bureaucracy.
That really tightens the focus.
I like that it.
Keeps the momentum going right
into the conclusion.
OK.
So we've talked about the stakes
and the structure.
Let's go back to the core
historical frame.
The whole argument really hangs
on the fact that Judea and Egypt
were both managed by Rome.
The family was just moving from
a client Kingdom to an imperial
province.
That is the cornerstone, no
doubt, but while the peace does
an amazing job detailing what
the Holy Family was not.
Not refugees, not crossing
national borders.
It stopped short of really
defining what they were.
Interesting.
While the material meticulously
details what the Holy Family
was, not refugees, strengthening
the argument requires explicitly
defining what their legal and
social status was as movers
within the specific context of
the Roman imperial system.
The weakness is that it relies
so much on negation.
Not this, not that, right?
It correctly says Roman subjects
traveled all over the empire,
but it doesn't fully exploit the
specific details of their move
from a client Kingdom, Judea, to
a full Roman province, Egypt.
It could be bolstered with more
positive terminology.
Exactly.
Give us the historical term for
what they were doing instead of
just rejecting the modern one.
So the suggestion is to take all
those great details from the
appendix and the main body and
use them to assign an active
historical identity to their
movement.
Yes, cement them firmly with the
known Roman administrative
practices.
I mean, think about the nuance
there.
They're moving from Herod's
client rule to a province run
directly by a Roman prefect.
That's a huge distinction that
needs to be hit harder.
It is.
So what would the practical
implications of that be for a
1st century person?
Well, primarily security and
predictability.
OK, in a client Kingdom, your
safety depends on the whims of a
local ruler.
And in this case, that's Herod,
who's famously paranoid, right?
By moving to an imperial
province like Egypt, they step
under the direct administration
of Rome.
They're under a system that was,
at least in theory, much more
predictable.
They weren't seeking asylum from
a hostile foreign power.
No, they were seeking A safer
administrative jurisdiction
within the same imperial power.
That makes the argument so much
more robust.
It uses the very structure of
the Roman system to explain the
move, and I remember the
appendix mentioned that travel
was only really restricted by
cost and safety.
That detail is vital.
It needs to be in the main body.
You think so?
Absolutely.
Use it to show their movement
was actually facilitated by
Roman infrastructure.
Their problem was local safety
Herod, not some imperial legal
barrier.
Their ability to move was a
feature of the Empire, not a
bug.
So since the whole paper is
about terminological precision,
the ultimate actionable step
here is to provide a better
term.
Yes, you have to fill the vacuum
you create by rejecting refugee.
So you assign a label that
captures all this complexity.
You have to.
I'd suggest something precise
like internal imperial
relocation.
Internal imperial relocation.
That's strong.
It's formal.
Or maybe Roman subjects in
localized flight from client
tyranny, Something like that.
I like internal imperial
relocation.
It immediately shifts the focus.
It's not about what the argument
is against, it's about what the
argument establishes.
And it forces the reader to
engage with that historical
complexity because you've given
them this robust affirmative
label to use instead.
It just beautifully
operationalizes the entire
critique.
By asserting a positive
historical identity for them,
the author achieves both
historical accuracy and protects
the modern definition of a
refugee.
Exactly.
This is an exceptionally strong
piece of work.
These adjustments are really
just about making sure it's
argument lands with maximum
clarity.
Let's do a quick summary of the
three main refinements first.
Maximize the significance,
expand that conclusion, connect
the historical precision
directly to why it matters
today, and show the tangible
stakes.
Right, and use the author's own
definition of flight as a
constructive alternative. 2nd,
we focused on structure.
We recommended strategically
integrating that unique
supernatural dimension, the
Angel, the dream, much earlier
in the flow.
Using it as specialized evidence
against a generalized
displacement rather than leaving
it as a standalone theological
point.
Finally, we talked about
deepening the historical
definition, moving beyond what
they weren't, to define what
their movement actually was
within the Roman system.
And adopting a strong
affirmative counter term like
internal imperial relocation.
The death of expertise here is
just so clear.
It really is.
These enhancements are aimed at
perfecting the communication of
a crucial historical insight and
giving your argument the
powerful conclusion it deserves.
We invite you to implement these
suggestions and submit your
revised material back to the.
Historical status of the Holy
Family's journey.
So the sources we're looking at
really question whether we
should call Jesus, Mary and
Joseph refugees.
The main point is that it's
historically inaccurate.
Because we're kind of pushing
our modern legal ideas back onto
the ancient world.
OK, first take away.
Their journey from Judea to
Egypt was basically an internal
move.
I mean, think about it.
Both places were under Roman
control, so they weren't
crossing a.
Foreign border like we would
today.
It was all one big system and
Roman subjects could travel
pretty freely, no visas needed.
Second, that word refugee itself
is a huge anachronism.
It's a legal term from the 20th
century to find after World War
2.
It implies concepts like nation
States and asylum processes,
which just weren't a thing in
the 1st century.
So while they were absolutely
fleeing danger, that specific
label doesn't really fit.
And finally, the reason for
their flight was pretty unique.
The biblical story says it was a
direct supernatural warning.
An Angel told Joseph in a dream.
This makes it really different
from, say, a whole community
being displaced.
It was a specific instruction
for one single family.
So the key distinction here is
that the Holy Family's flight
was a movement for safety within
one empire, which is
fundamentally different from our
modern legal concept of crossing
international borders to seek
asylum.